Let's say that we have a path at the xy level
This is the Y axis, and this is the x-axis, in the mesari
It will look like this.
Let's say it looks like it; try to draw a bit of
A default path, let's say we'll go in a clockwise direction
Like it along our course.
We could call this path - where we are going in reverse direction
Clock - we can call this path C.
Suppose we also have a vector field.
Our field will be a bit unusual;
Will be called P.
P from the level XY.
That it only has a component i, or that all its vectors are only
Complications of component i, which represents the unit vector.
So P from level x is a multiplicity of the vector of unit i.
There is no component i, so if you have a conception of
This vector field, all these vectors, are multiples
Of the unit vector i.
Or they can be reversible complications, where they can
They also go in this direction.
But they do not go in a diagonal direction or they do not go up.
They all go in a direction from left to right or from right to left.
This is what the vector field will look like.
Now what I'm interested in is knowing
· Linear integration along the path of CSS-C or C-orbit
The CSS path is C-of-P, point, and integrator on r, which is our standard only
Type as a way to solve linear integration.
We have seen what DR means in the past.
dr is equal to dx multiplied by i plus dy multiplied vector unit j.
You might say, is not dx dt multiplied by dt?
Let me write it down: Can not write dr like dt, dx multiplied
dti plus dy and dt multiplied by dtj?
And it can, but if I imagine these differences
It can be canceled, and you're just left with the DX and
dy, we have seen it several times.
I will leave it on this form because we hope if
We are careful, we will not have to deal with the third lab
The third parameter t.
So let's just look at it in this ha-here shape with
Just dx and dy.
So this integration can be rewritten as a linear integration,
Curve C - Let me do this here below.
Linear integration on the path of the C curve from the point P dr.
So we'll take the multiplication for each transaction, let's say
That the parameter for component i, so we get the P - I will do so
In green, in fact I will do this in purple - until we get P of the XR multiplied
dx plus - well there is no zero multiplied by j dy multiplied by zero multiplied by dy
Will produce zero - well this is our simplified linear integration
So here it is.
This is equal to this original integration at the top here, where we are
Literally we will just take linear integration around this path.
Now I said we were playing with our cards, we do not have to
Dealing with the third variable, t; so we may be
Are able to resolve this integration only in terms of x.
So let's see if we can do that.
So let's look at the small and great points for x.
Those look like our smallest point for x.
Let us call that.
Let us call our tenth point as the maximum; let us call that b.
What we can do we can break up this curve in
The two functions are x. y Functions x.
So this down here one can call it y1 x.
This is just a standard curve; you know when we were just
Handle the standard calculus, that's just because you can
Imagine this and X and x function.
This is the x2 y2.
Just like that.
So you can imagine two paths; one path is determined by y1 X-
Let me do it in a different color; purple - one track
Set it to x1 as we go from x to x equals
Equals B, and another path then set it x x2 as we
Going from x is equal to B to S.
This is our curve.
So what we can do, we can write this integrated -
It is the same thing that is integral - as this is equal
Integrated - we will first track this I-X go
From to BBS.
I can say p l x and y, but we know along this
The y-path of the x function.
Therefore we say y1 of x and x.
Wherever we see r we replace it with
y1 x, dx.
That will cover this first course; I will do so in the same color.
We can imagine that this is c1.
This is kind of the first half of our curve - well it's not
Exactly which takes half - but that we have the right of that
Point to that point.
And then we want to complete the circle.
Maybe you will, and I will do so in yellow.
Which will be equal - sorry we are going to
Add these two-plus integers of x equal to b
x is equal - we do it in this same color of x.
Now y2 will be y.
Wherever you see Y, you can replace with y2
X along this curve.
y2 x, dx.
This is actually getting interesting, you
We may already see where I'm going with this.
This is the c2 curve.
Very I think you would appreciate if you take the c1 and union
c2, we've got our whole curve.
So let's see if we can simplify this little integrated.
One good thing we want to do, we may want to make
Their end points are the same.
So if you swap a bb here, it just turns
Negative integral.
Where you can make this to AB, which is in, and then do so
Plus sign in subtraction.
Now we have to rewrite the whole thing as equals
Integrated from to B for this thing, V and Y1 from
x minus this thing, minus P of x and y2 for x, and then
All that times dx.
I type it in a third color.
Now, I'm going to do something a bit arbitrary, though
I think you'll appreciate why I did this by the end of this
Video, and that once the process is very simple.
What I'm going to do I'm going to swap these two.
So basically I'm going to double this whole thing off
Negative 1, or basically hit and split
1 negative.
So I could hit this negative first and then hit
The exterior before the negative 1, will not be changed
Integrated; I hit twice before negative 1.
So if you swap these two things, if I multiply inside times
1 negative, since this will be equal to - doing abroad
From integration, to b.
If I hit the inside - I'll do dx here - if I'm
Hit inside the negative 1 integration,
Switch these two players.
So it becomes P x of y2 x.
And then you're going to be minus P x and y1 x.
Get my hands a little chaotic.
But I just can not just multiply the inside with subtraction 1.
Do not want to change the integrated, so I multiplied
Inside Banqas 1, let me hit the outside
Of minus 1.
Since multiplied minus 1 twice, these two
Things equivalent.
Or it can be said that this is no denying because.
Either way, I think that I appreciate that I own
Integration has changed at all, and numerically.
I am multiplied at home and abroad minus 1.
Now I'm going to do the next step, it might sound a little bit
Foreign to you a bit, but I think you will appreciate it.
It may be obvious to you if you have done recently
Some double integrations.
So this thing can be rewritten as incomplete from integrated to
B - Let me do a new color-P function,
y evaluate the y2 subtraction x - let me make it very clear;
This is y equals y2-x minus this rating function
In y equals y1 x.
And of course all those times are dx.
This statement and what we have seen here - and this
Statement right here - exactly identical.
Hence if we assume that a partial derivative of capital P
As for the existing r, we hope you'll realize-and
This will focus a little because I do not want to
Mix you up on the move.
Let me write out this integral.
This will be equal to - this kind of stylish
Results, we started building on a very neat
The final document, which probably will have to take the next video to
Do - so do dx out.
If we assume that the capital P has derived the partial, this
Right here is exactly the same.
This right here is the same thing as partial
P is derived for y, dy, anti-adaptive of
That from y1 x to y2 x.
I want to make you feel comfortable that these two
Things equivalent.
And realize that they are the equivalent, you probably
You just have to start here and then go to it.
We used to see this; we used to see double
The parcel of like this, and then the very first step say, okay
To solve this dual integration we start the integral inside
Right there, we say, "OK" let's take an antirative
This is for yes.
So if you take the micro-integrative
For y, you're going to end up with a p.
And since these are integrated, specific, limits
In terms of x, you evaluate it
From y equals x y2, you're going to subtract from
That y equals y1 x.
Usually we start with something like this, we
Go to something like that.
This kind of unusual that we started, we kind of solved, and we
Started with a clear integrated solution, and then
We slowly built into a specific integrated.
So hopefully you realize that this is correct, and that this
Just kind of we're going in reverse direction
Which we usually do.
And if you realize that, then you've just created
Very neat result.
Because what is this right here?
Let me go again, let me see if it can fit everything.
I have some function - I am assuming that partial of
P exists for y-but has some function
Find out about the XY plane.
As you know, we can imagine that we are dealing in
The three dimensions now.
We will draw a little bit fussy.
Where y is, which is x, which is z, so these, you can imagine,
Is some surface; it just happens to be a partial
P for the tenth.
So it's some surface on board xy like this.
And what are we doing?
We take integrated double under this surface,
Around this area.
Limits are defined in the region in terms of y
y2 and y1 of x.
So you literally have this curve.
This is y2 at the top, y1 at the bottom.
And we mainly do the above size.
So if you imagine with the rule - the whole word for this
The area will be within this curve, and then rise
The function will be partial of P for y.
It is about to be a bit hard for me to draw, but this is
Basically some kind of volume, if you want to
Imagine it that way.
But the results are really neat here if you call this area
r, only we have simplified this line integrated.
This was a special one.
It was only an x ​​element, vector pathology, but we only have
Simplifying this embedded line is being equivalent to - perhaps
I would like to write this integrated line because that's what it is in
Really neat results.
We just created that thing here, right that
Is the same as our original one, so let me write this down.
The enclosed line is enclosed around the G curve of x, dx,
We just created that this is the same thing as
Double integrated cross zone r- This is the region
r-On Part F in relation to yes.
We can write de, dx, or da can write, whatever you
Want to write, but this is dual integration
Across that area.
The neat thing here is the use of a vector field that was only
x-component, we were able to connect an embedded line
Dual integration above the area - oh, I forgot
Something very important.
We had a negative sign here.
So this was an introduction here.
Or we could even put the subtraction here, but I think you
Get a general idea.
In the next video clip, I'm going to do the exact same thing with
It only has vector vector area in the direction-r.
And then we'll do both and we'll end up
With Greene's theorem.